police in Germany claim they have foiled
a terror plot in Berlin authorities in
the German capital have arrested a
suspect of Russian origin there a Europe
correspondent Peter Oliver brings us
more police in Berlin have arrested a 31
year old Russian man from the Chechen
Republic on suspicion of planning a
terror attack now what the target of
this attack may have been hasn't been
revealed but what prosecutors have said
in a statement is that the intent was to
kill as many people as possible now the
man has been named as Magda med Allie's
see was standard protocol here in
Germany to just give the first name and
the first letter of the last name for
anybody who's been arrested but he's
understood to have worked in the past
with a partner who's currently in French
custody now he is a 22 year old that has
been named as Clement B who's currently
in French detention after he was
arrested back in April of 2017 prior to
the French general election he was
picked up on terror charges as well now
the two men are understood to have been
planning an attack together back in 2016
but they called that off after police
became suspicious of the actions of
Magnum ed Alesi and started to
investigate him the 31 year old from the
Chechen Republic remained here in Berlin
however the 22 year old named his
Clermont B he fled first to Aachen and
then into France where he was eventually
arrested
well 31 year-old Magnum ed Alesi will
face the federal court on Thursday where
charges will be put before him
you